look what came out it's exciting it's so
exciting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
guys I'm so excited it finally came the
1 million subscriber plaque from YouTube
something came in the mail I'm like what
is this thing and then there's this logo
here let me show you look
YouTube YouTube and like this is it why
would so much bigger than this silver I
should get the silver one this is the
silver one for a hundred thousand this
is the million so what's nice
what what's next is ten million it's a
it's a big diamond one or something ten
million we're coming for you ten million
okay let's open this up alrighty here it
comes it comes oh wow look at this guys
look at this look at that
YouTube YouTube look at that box okay
hold on let me fill this messes up
messes are part of the fun okay if you
can't make a mess can't make a mess then
yeah I did a good job
Oh without me just by yourself
you know I open the bottle get a gallon
in the box OH
okay I need to smell look at that Teemo
team was not sure what what Nina's
coming but we'd love her okay here it is
ready guys
[Music]
I hit my face okay here we go the reveal
Chella I broke the box at the bottom oh
we can't put that together
alright well forget the YouTube box it's
a big black piece of foam there's a
letter okay look guys sorry you have to
read the letter letter came first you're
bigger than Vancouver you're bigger than
Venice you're even bigger than Las Vegas
1 million subscribers maybe you've
imagined that day a long time or maybe
you've never thought you'd go so big
believe you guys believe either way not
much can match a satisfaction to finding
out that your creativity that your idea
is that your voice speaks to 1 million
people across the globe we know the
beating with the touch the lives of so
many people is reward enough
but we're incredibly proud of all you've
done so we hope you'll accept this gold
creator Award as a token of our esteem
I will accept YouTube I will accept with
your track record
we suspect that you'll only that you're
only going to keep growing and we can't
wait to see you reach the next milestone
10 million subscribers I can't wait -
come on guys let's do it let's make it
happen
it may seem far away not that far away
but remember the days when you were
psyched to have a thousand on key I do
remember it was awesome every single
subscriber is awesome you've amazed us
keep daring keep dreaming big and keep
creating you're the inspiration for
everything we do sincerely Susan CEO of
YouTube boom alright put that aside the
reveal
oh okay slowly make them wait Nina knows
how to keep things in suspense a bit
here okay give my face that's the
criteria Oh
oh yeah hope to the hit team oh sorry
team Oh you're a good boy yes lovely
yeah there's a glare Hey look at that
1 million thank you guys thank you guys
thank you guys okay have you Carmichael
congratulations on passing 1 million
subscribers that's all you guys we love
you when I got the package I was saying
how I need to we're gonna make a video
but I need to have a message this is a
big milestone what should I say I Nina I
was talking about consistency so that I
thought I might share a couple of
stories that have helped me get here
that may be educational for you guys and
at the end Nina is gonna share a story
of her own it's about me and the people
who support me so I'll share a couple
Nina's gonna share one at the ends him
barn you time to think of what you're
gonna say and speak loudly into the
microphone yeah I'm very loud ok hear
that what she's angry number one
Nina reminded me today about the
importance of consistency I did a
Facebook post just over 4 years ago
where I was I crossed a million views on
my channel and I looked at the post and
I had 7,000 something subscribers so I
went from 7000 subscribers to 1 point
whatever we're at now million just by
making videos every day you know just by
being consistent 2 to 3 videos every
single day for four years continue to
work continue to grind continue to make
it better and we're here I think so
often people just give up too soon they
start something and they stop they start
and you just don't give it enough time
to be consistent it was a great analogy
I heard around you're trying to boil
water to make pasta or make rice and
you'll never boil the water if you turn
it on for five seconds and then turn it
off for ten minutes and then turn it on
for five seconds and turn it off for 10
minutes the but the water will never
boil you'll never be able to make your
rice and it does what a lot of people do
they start and they stop and so
hopefully this helps encourage you to
just keep going whatever you're doing
just keep going just keep going just
keep going just keep going and
eventually you'll hit your goals
point number two early in my youtube
career I'd almost you know I was told I
wasn't good enough
you know I joined an agency and they
told me I wasn't good enough and I just
worked hard to keep getting better and I
have no natural talent for this guys
like it may not come across now in my
videos as you watch but in making five
six thousand videos you just you get
better right just by the repetition and
just by practicing and just trying to
dedicate yourself to improve my first
videos were terrible I did everything
myself
I was nervous I had my sister or someone
on my team coming to focus the camera
and then I had to have them leave the
room because I couldn't do anything with
them in the room oh it's too nervous
even with my sister some of my team I
was too nervous to deal with them if you
want to learn something you can you can
get good at something if you just have
the passion and keep going and I think a
lot of times people expect to be great
and they give up way too soon because
they suck at the beginning at the start
of anything you're gonna suck period
right the first time you try to learn
how to ride a bike learn French
cook a meal you sucked and so don't
expect to be great at anything that
you're doing at the beginning and I
think the challenge is because you know
what looks good you know what a great
YouTube video looks like but then you
can't go out and make it a lot of people
see that as well I'm never gonna be able
to do it just because you can't do it
right now it doesn't mean that you can't
do it at some point and so expect to
suck right like try your hardest ryu
best but expect to suck and then just
try to make it better the next day and
use other people's wins whoever you look
up to in your field the best of the best
use them as a as a push forward not down
use them as inspiration to get better
not well they're so good and I'm never
gonna be like that right by continuing
to focus on your craft you will get
better and you can become the best you
can accomplish your goals just because
you love it and I think I should have a
third one you know three and three is
good I think building out a support
system becomes really helpful so I'm
really grateful for this woman right
here this special lady in my life
she's Nina we love her she's about to
share something massively insightful
hahaha coming soon but you know it's the
team effort I've got wonderful people on
my team as well at the start it was all
me I did everything and it was slow and
it really socked him and then as I grew
I brought on editors Christina and her
husband Sam have been amazing I brought
on a cameraman Jason who helps film a
lot of my stuff in a tedious to do I
have Ivan who helps me do a lot of
research I have Luca and Sandra who've
helped out a lot in the comments it's
been a team effort and I think one
understanding what you are great at I
have Michael Jordan level talent at or
desire to and then building a team
around what you're not so good at so I
never wanted to be a great editor so I
could focus on being in front of the
camera and not behind it and all behind
the scenes stuff so as soon as I could
afford to like I'm gonna build it
so that I can grow and then just the
emotional support whether that's having
people in your life like Nina who you
are and support you and I do crazy
things all the time like like like paint
my nails believe orange with racing
stripes on them I do crazy things and
it's amazing to have someone as a
partner to support you and not judge you
and here you are and if you don't have
that then I think the other thing has
really helped me is the videos
themselves
I think bigger I act bolder I want to go
off and do bigger things because of my
own videos I make my videos for myself I
get inspired by the video that I make
and then I share that with you guys and
so that's been a super super amazing
journey for me to be on and and but
every year I grow more confident more
bold or one to take big risks so those
were my three tips three lessons that
I've learned on this crazy amazing
journey to 1 million and as we move
onwards to 10 and I bought enough time I
think now for Nina do we have enough
time we buy enough time you get you need
a few more seconds a few more final
seconds that she goats there on the
nerves and is ready to drop some insane
knowledge on you guys right now it's
consistency I think I can't have a
couple examples like when we worked like
before we have Shawn doing the trainings
we already have a pattern what to do how
to like my video or the routine we just
eat whatever we're not well not like
super junky but we
we just eat whatever and we're our
weight you're just going up well not
really going up I find huge just like
it's not it's not that one without
losing a lot of the way but that since
we have Shawn that we follow that we
have like everyday we have a routine and
we follow it we follow our routine and
then we're like we're dropping we're
losing our work we're losing our way
we're losing way and then we also like
being building muscles they we
consistently doing stuff that that what
he what our trainer tells us and yeah we
were working towards I would go out our
goal so yeah be consistent and also like
if I may also be important you have to
have a goal what you what you want at
the end so that you could be consistent
to go to work towards that yes sometimes
like when I'm working I want if I want
to learn something I will make sure
every day I'll practice to do that thing
to to do that thing to be consistent to
work towards they're pretty good I'm
smart gonna rule so question for you
guys I would love to know from all the
videos that I've done there's been a ton
of videos at least 4,000 plus that have
gone live another thousand plus that
I've never gone live I want to know what
video I - questions - questions
regression special special because it's
a 1 million first one is what was the
video that you first remember brought
you here if you can it was the first
video or like the first memorable video
or the first video that made you want to
subscribe to the channel like what was
the first introduction video that that
you came to the channel or made you
subscribe I want to know what that is
and - what is your favorite video of all
time that's been on this channel when I
meet people when I meet fans on the
street like that's usually the question
that I asked them one of those two and
so I'd love to know from you let's fill
up the chat what was the video that
brought you here initially made you
subscribe and - what is your favorite
video of all time on this channel leave
it down on the comments below guys
you know I'm a little bit at a loss of
words it's humbling this thing is
ginormous you know figure out a spot
that put it in the office
you guys are my fuel and my energy and
the oxygen every day I wake up and I get
to do meaningful work I mean check out
your comments and I know that the stuff
that I'm doing is having an impact and
it just means so much and so thank you
thank you thank you for your love for
your support and here's the ten million
let's take it happen happy weekend thank
you for joining for watching
if you guys want us to do in that there
would you rather Nina likes the would
you rather challenges do they want than
what your other video or do they have
questions for another would you rather
video if they want us to do that with
you rather then also add some questions
okay
okay put that down below to thank you
guys hope you had a great weekend we
believe in you hope you continue to
believe and whatever
[Applause]
[Laughter]